depuis qu'il est entré dans l'éducation
nationale patrice romain prend des notes
sur tout et sur tous et il fait des
livres sur les élèves les parents et les
profs
avec ce nouvel ouvrage un principal ne
devrais pas dire ça
ce livre résume une année scolaire sur
un collège dans fin de compte j'ai un
petit peu j'ai rassemblé toutes les
notes que je prends depuis plusieurs
décennies sur tout ce qui se passe dans
le collège et ensuite j'ai fabriqué mes
personnages
chaque chapitre représente un mois de
l'année dans lequel ces personnages
évoluent toute ressemblance avec des
individus ayant existé ne serait pas
forcément fortuite ni involontaire
madame st dictats monsieur bo bo je
m'arrête madame teresa monsieur mon fou
comprenne qui voudra
par exemple les professeurs qui qui
n'était pas violent au niveau travail
j'essaie regroupés autour d'un
personnage que j'ai appelé monsieur
pépère la salle des profs refusent des
enseignants a été source d'inspiration
fil des années attention patrice romain
ne connaît que trop la difficulté du
métier
la seule vocation de son livre et de
faire sourire
c'est sympa de voir l'envers du décor en
fait surtout pour les parents les choses
comme ça pour les gens qui vont acheter
ce livre
et enfin découvrir tous les travers un
petit peu des professeurs sur le temps
et d'humour je trouve ça vraiment
intéressant et c'est sympa de d'avoir un
principal que ce genre de 10
vrai visage des pauvres ce sont des
humains sont des personnes c'est vrai
qu'ils ont un rôle à tenir une image à
tenir mais sont comme tout le monde j'ai
sûrement la lâcheté lire parce que c'est
ça reflète le personnage
enfin les parents et aussi les profs
d'ailleurs depuis qu'elles ont lu les
ouvrages consacrés au mode excuses des
parents c'est maman avoue vérifier
plusieurs fois ce qu'elle s'inscrive
dans le carnet de leurs enfants